more than 100 guns are off the streets
in Miami after people sold them to the
police with no questions asked
gun buyback events are one of the ways
that states work to fight gun violence
California is the only state with a
database that cross-references gun
owners with people who have criminal
convictions restraining orders or
serious mental health issues Carter
Evans went along with a special task
force charged with taking firearms away
from people who are not allowed to have
them most of these agents with the
California Department of Justice can't
show their faces on TV she has an
out-of-state felon conviction
you're going to people's homes who are
known to have guns right and a criminal
conviction in some cases right it's 0 to
100 in a second we wrote along with
special agent Sam Richardson and his
team as they track down people who are
prohibited from having firearms yes
three firearms still registered in his
name
their goal is to take them away we're
about to go to a guy's house who is a
convicted felon he's got a domestic
violence restraining order and he's on
probation for those reasons he's not
legally allowed to have access to guns
agents searched his home and came out
with two rifles where did you find them
I'm in his closet and this guy knows
he's not supposed to have guns that's
right
did you know those guns were in there no
did you find ammunition as well they're
able to track down these guns because
California is the only state in the
country that keeps a database of
registered gun owners when someone has a
criminal conviction or is deemed
mentally incompetent that person's name
is flagged in the armed and prohibited
person system known as apps how many
people are on this list of yours as of
this morning I believe we had a little
over 10,000 special agent-in-charge
Tony Liddell how many guns are you
getting off the streets every year
thousands
it's tedious work in the nine hours we
were with agents they went to six
locations and recovered two guns is it
worth all the hard work yes it is I feel
like what we're doing by taking one gun
at a time off the streets of Cal
Oya is making our community safer but
that's hard to prove there is no
federally funded research into gun
violence or prevention programs like
this UC Davis researcher dr. Garrett
winter Butte is using state funds to
study the effectiveness of apps our
hypothesis is taking guns away from
high-risk people will reduce their risk
of committing violence down the road if
we find that apps works I'll be talking
to anybody who will listen about this
program I'm sure there are people out
there who are gonna see this and say
this is just the beginning they're
coming to take all our guns right that's
it's not the way this program works this
program specifically targets a certain
class of people have lost the right to
have a firearm so you're not trying to
disarm the good guys no not at all for
CBS this morning Carter Evans Los
Angeles two takeaways how dangerous
these cops jobs are and how brave Carter
is to be going with them yeah you better
hope the guys aren't looking out the
window but nine hours six locations only
two guns out of a possible 10,000 the
world will see if other states follow
suit